perhaps odd sounding to the outside
world have helped make the cut and
thrust of debate less personal and
direct and have helped in a small way to
maintain the dignity of the house and
the honor of its members
because politics is an honorable pursuit
and in my experience of over 30 years in
public life
the vast majority of those who seek
political office are motivated to
improve the lives of others and fight
for what they believe to be
theresa may they're speaking at the
institute for uh government you can see
uh there let me just get out of the way
of the uh picture you can see there the
uh
lectern the pogen in front of the door
of number 10 outside number 11
staff
serving the prime minister have been
gathering waiting uh to hear the
statement that we're expecting in the
next 10 minutes or so andrew griffith
for example
we can see uh standing there the prime
minister's director of uh policy
uh and uh other members of the staff
there standing outside at number 11
gathering to hear the resignation
statement of the prime minister expected
at 12 30. they're currently plugging in
at the podium outside number 10. this is
what traditionally happens uh when a
prime minister stands down you can see
on your screen there's james dodge in
the middle of the bright color to his
right is andrew griffiths he was the
prime minister's policy chief he used to
be the chief financial officer actually
at sky
plc uh behind
andrew
behind andrew griffith you can see gito
hari he's the prime minister's uh
director of communications and i'm
wondering too whether carrie johnson
might come out i remember when the prime
minister was appointed
to the post that she stood there with
members and staff if we look down the
other side of the street i don't think
you can see this but there are mps also
gathering now i don't know if we can
flip the camera around but
that i can see conor burns one of the
prime ministers uh oldest allies i don't
know if you can see there's people in
the way but yes there you go
you can see robert passed
an itv all the crews on the street but
you can see their uh minis uh mps and
there was some talk this morning um that
the
number 10 team had asked for mps uh to
come to come behind boris johnson uh
when he comes out and and some of them
are gathering there not a huge group i
have to say but there they all are i
think that's is that heather wheeler at
the front so i think it is the white in
the white jacket embracing some of her
colleagues so embracing some people yeah
as you say johnny mercer i can also uh
just glimpse behind that
there's alan mack there who is i think a
whip
um
i don't know all of their names actually
daniel karensky and peter brown also
there as you say bear not perhaps the
largest grouping of mps ever but
certainly it does feel like that edict
has gone out from number 10 that more
supportive mps
should
come to the streets ready to hear the
prime minister's statement so what we
have uh here uh is outside the door of
number 11 the members of staff
at number 10 and number 11
coming out to here at the other end of
the street is the gathering of
mps as well
so everyone really getting ready here
the last check to be made to the podium
they are
making these work getting those wires
ready
from boris johnson it's a speech
but he didn't want to have to make we
are expecting him to come out of that
door at shortly to give the reservation
statement that he has been resisting
for the last few days but it will be we
expect very different in tone
to explanation speeches of the past he's
determined
to keep going on in the role as the kind
of caretaker leader if you like after
setting out a timetable for his uh
resignation
for some months until the autism
until
the next person is appointed
if you just if you just can pan over to
uh
see there's sorry there's just been a
run of new people now coming out all of
the number ten team now coming out
filling up the street and i can see that
uh his communications trees there's
rosie bates williams there's stephanie's
uh you can see if you move to number 11
sorry yeah
at the end you can see now uh his comms
team have come out uh all his senior
members of staff uh they're now waiting
and you can see the street has removed
the the lady in the floor just like
behind simone finn baroness finn one of
his uh key uh advisors and was once
actually an advisor to remember to
michael gove
she's there one of his i think she's a
deputy chief
of staff so the boris johnson's team now
all out there uh as we await for the
prime minister and i have to say though
sophie in terms of the appeal to get mps
out there's not a massive group of mps
there is there
there is it certainly i think we should
be able to hopefully have a look at some
of the emps
who are gathered there and as you say
beth
to be honest if it is true which it
seems like it was uh the number
10
have um
have made the appeal for mps to so like
cameroon has made the mps trying to get
uh to have a look at the mps who've
gathered as best was just saying is
number 10 made the appeal
for the supportive mps to come to the
street to show their support for boris
johnson that is not a great
number of mps who have actually uh
answered that uh call a few people that
we've managed to spot
connor burns allen mack heather wheeler
peter bone daniel karinsky but clearly
that is not a huge number of mps and
perhaps uh suggesting there uh that even
though uh the mps have uh answered boris
johnson's caller and he has managed to
refill
the audio one two three four five six
good stuff
i mean looking at that i don't know how
many how many mps would you say they're
third i reckon about 30. i mean for a
prime minister that two and a half years
ago won a majority of 80 the most
successful
conservative leader at the ballot box
since margaret thatcher totally crushing
uh david cameron at the ballot box at
least and really that isn't a massive
group of mps
here today given uh how many uh opened
their seats to him back in 2019 but i
think it reflects sophie the bitterness
uh between this prime minister and his
parliamentary party i was saying
yesterday in in the commons it was
visceral it was vicious
it gets like that towards the end
because for boris johnson he was in the
fight for his political life and when
you get to the end game like that it
gets nasty and
and it really did deteriorate the
atmosphere
and obviously a number of mps have
thought no i'm not going to come along
and stand behind you i think the mps
might be standing behind stand behind
him um i guess he would like that as a
show of strength but let's see see what
they do it's interesting isn't though
because if it is intended as a show of
strength which you have to assume it is
you can only muster up about 30 mps you
do have to wonder if that was perhaps
the show's trend that was intended jacob
reached morgan and johnny
can you move we're trying to show you
sorry let me just let me talk to you
about it as the camera moves over joe
now hopefully cut the shots number
one of the prime minister's key
lieutenants there he is
choggam with us actually it was lovely i
i got a little sight of that lovely baby
there is carrie johnson and next to her
nadine doris uh the prime minister's
closest ally uh and look there's the
little baby and i don't know where wilf
is they've got a toddler
as well i mean to be honest probably uh
quite risky uh having a toddler out uh
on the downstream well the toddler did
not come on the trip which um as anyone
knows who takes a toddler on a plane is
probably best advised uh yes so look
there we have it chris heaton harris
there's carrie
let's give nothing away
she looks actually lovely doesn't she
that red dress and the little baby
wrongly there she is she's sweet little
baby she's only nine months old
um and the dean doris and we are waiting
for the prime minister uh the door is
opening here he comes let's listen
good afternoon everybody good afternoon
everybody
good afternoon
it thank you thank you
it is clearly now the will
of the parliamentary conservative party
that there should be a new leader of
that party and therefore a new prime
minister and i've agreed with segren
brady the chairman of our backbench mps
that the process of choosing that new
leader should begin now and the
timetable will be announced next week
and i've today appointed a cabinet to
serve as i will until a new leader is in
place
so i want to say to the millions of
people who voted for us in 2019 many of
them voting conservative for the first
time
thank you
for that incredible mandate the biggest
conservative majority since 1987
the biggest share of the vote since
1979.
and the reason i have fought so hard in
the last few days to continue to deliver
that mandate in person
was not just because i wanted to do so
but because i felt it was my job
my duty
my obligation to you to continue to do
what we promised in 2019
and of course i'm immensely proud of the
achievements of this government from
getting brexit done to settling our
relations with the continent for over
half a century reclaiming
the power for this country to make its
own laws in parliament getting us all
through the pandemic delivering the
fastest vaccine rollout in europe the
fastest exit from lockdown and in the
last few months leading the west in
standing up to putin's aggression in
ukraine
and let me say now to the people of
ukraine that i know that we in the uk
will continue to back your fight for
freedom for as long as it takes
and
at the same time in this country we've
been pushing forward a vast program of
investment in infrastructure and skills
and technology the biggest in a century
because if i have one insight into human
beings it is that genius and talent and
enthusiasm and imagination
are evenly distributed throughout the
population but opportunity is not and
that's why we must keep leveling up keep
unleashing the potential of every part
of the united kingdom
and if we
can do that in this country we will be
the most prosperous in europe and in the
last few days i've tried to persuade my
colleagues that it would be eccentric to
change governments when we're delivering
so much and when we have such a vast
mandate and when we're actually only a
handful of points behind in the polls
even in mid-term after quite a few
months of pretty relentless sledging and
when
the economic scene is so difficult
domestically and
internationally and i regret and not to
have been successful in those arguments
and of course it's painful and not to be
able to see
through
so many ideas and projects myself but as
we've seen
at westminster the herd instinct is
powerful when the herd moves it moves
and my friends in politics no one is
remotely indispensable and our brilliant
and darwinian system will produce
another leader
equally committed to taking this country
forward through tough times
not just helping families to get through
it but changing and improving the way we
do things cutting burdens on businesses
and families and yes cutting taxes
because that is the way to generate the
growth and the income we need to pay for
great public services
and to that new leader i say whoever he
or she may be i say i will give you as
much support as i can
and to you the british public
i know that there will be many people
who are relieved
and uh perhaps quite a few who will also
be disappointed
and i want you to know how sad i am
to be giving up
the best job in the world
that them's the breaks
i want to thank carrie
and our children all the members of my
family who have had to put up with so
much for so long
i want to thank the peerless british
civil service for all the help and
support that you have given our police
our emergency services and of course our
fantastic nhs who at critical moment
helped to extend my own period in office
as well as our armed services and our
agencies that are so admired around the
world
and are interfaciable conservative party
members and supporters whose selfless
campaigning makes our democracy possible
i want to thank the wonderful staff here
at checkers
to here at number 10 and of course at
checkers
and our fantastic prop force detectives
the one group by the way who never leak
above all
i want to thank
you the british public
for the immense privilege that you
have given me
and i want you to know
that from now on until the new prime
minister is in place
your interests
will be served
and the government of the country
will be carried on
being prime minister
is an education in itself
i've traveled to every part of the
united kingdom
and in addition to the beauty of our
natural world
i've found so many people possessed
of such boundless british originality
and so willing to tackle old problems in
new ways
that i know that even if things can
sometimes
seem dark now
our future together
is golden
thank you all very much
thank you
boris johnson uh they're talking about
how sad he is to give up the best job in
the world but thems the breaks
thank you for an incredible mandate he
said to the people who gave him the
mandate after that 2019 uh general
election uh victory but the darwinian
system he said will now produce a new
leader let's go to uh beth rigby uh
shall we beth what would you make of
that statement
well it was it was kind of trademark but
it was vintage boris johnson wasn't it
uh it was as i thought it would be
he was talking about his greatest hits
it had humor in there it was tinged
with sadness
and it was also very dignified actually
a very dignified speech i thought in
which he
held his head high he accepted that he
didn't want to leave
and he gave well one thing about boyce
johnson is he doesn't really give you
much emotion but but there what he does
is he uses language to show the emotion
and some of the things that you know
struck me he said of course it was
painful not to be able to see through
the project and as i said before he
rolled out the greatest hits he said how
proud he was to have got brexit done and
to put he said
and to give the country back the power
to make its own laws that's how he put
it uh he talked about leveling up we
must keep on uh levelling up and we must
fight for the freedom of ukraine for as
long as it takes he then went on to say
of course it is painful not to see
the projects through that i wanted to
and then he said in a characteristically
humorous
way he said but the herd
has moved and when the herd
moves it moves quickly and then he said
no one is remotely indispensable he'd
said how much he wanted uh to
stay on and then he said that the
darwinian system as he put it
will produce another leader who he said
he would give as much support as he
could
and then he touched upon
his divisiveness because he's batted it
off all the time but he said i know that
some of you many of you he said will be
relieved and some disappointed by my
resignation and he said
he was so sad to believe in the best job
in the world as he described it and then
he finished off by thanking
the public
for giving him as he said the immense
privilege of being able to serve as the
prime minister he said being prime
minister is an education
in itself
and he said about the boundless british
energy and enthusiasm that he had met
around the country and then he finally
ended
with you know he is a journalist he's a
good writer and he does good oratory he
said
it might feel dark now but the future
together is golden and with that the
applause there were no tears uh massive
applause and he went back and he also
thanked his wife parry johnson who was
watching on uh with their nine-month-old
baby romney oh yeah it was i thought
beth it was interesting talking
beforehand about the emotion of other uh
resignation statements we've seen
and in recent days we've been told that
boris johnson is in buoyant spirits and
there were no tears obviously from the
prime minister but i did get a sense we
got a flicker of emotion from him
perhaps more than he usually
shows when he was talking about how sad
he was to get the best job in the world
as she was saying talking quite frankly
about the reason that he's continued to
fight on so long perhaps a little bit of
an acknowledgement and that he has been
trying to hang on to the job until it
just became impossible yeah and you know
and he talked about you know he started
off by thanking the british people for
that huge mandate he wanted it to be
known that he was a winner once and he
won the biggest majority since margaret
thatcher and he wanted to remind
everyone of that and he explained that
that was the reason that he clung on for
so long that he felt that he had been
given a mandate
by the people and that mandate he felt
stood but he said as he acknowledged the
herd moved against him and once that
happened there really was nowhere else
for him to go but you know i didn't
expect to see boris johnson
shed a tear the most emotion i've ever
seen in boris johnson is him drop he
drops sometimes drops his head but he
wanted that to be a moment where he
projected confidence and optimism they
are the tickets if you like that
attracted the public to him in the first
place the can-do optimism the boris
johnson boosterism as we used to call it
and and really that that speech i think
had bucket loads of that in terms of the
delivery
but also look it's hard to hear any
prime minister talk about having to
leave that job it was hard to hear david
cameron do it theresa may boris johnson
because you know as he said it's the
best job in the world i'm sad to leave
it i didn't want to go
but i had to leave and that must be
absolutely
brutal to have to do that in the moment
but you know he was very composed he was
upbeat and i did as i said i thought
that was vintage at boris johnson he
gave us
his best version of himself there yes
certainly you can see uh around us
they are literally packing up at our
feet
i mean this is the brutality of politics
i think for the big moment
so all the cables were running along
here and now uh it's all been packed up
yeah certainly thank you so much for
your analysis
between our
well that is it we hear of course the
speech from uh boris johnson the
resignation speech where he spoke about
his when run through his greatest hits
that of course a big majority but also
expressed his frustration
in not being able to really follow
through on some of the mandate that he
was given in terms of big policies we
can bring in adam bolton now the former
sky news political editor and presenter
to discuss a bit of that and i did i
don't know if you agree adam detects a
tinge of regret in the boris johnson uh
speech saying he must we must keep
leveling up but it was frustrating not
to be able to continue in the work that
he'd started and it really has been a
premiership marked by outside events
covet the war in ukraine do you think
that will be a sense of something that
boris johnson i guess will regret
looking back on his legacy
well i'll leave aside the emotion if i
may the fact is this is a massive
political humiliation for boris johnson
uh who won a
great general election victory or led
his party to a great general election
victory but as he admitted lost the
confidence of his own party
within the space uh of uh two years
since that general election
i think
what's more important really is trying
to work out what's going to happen now
boris johnson
he didn't actually use the words i
resign
but he's clearly on the way out and
let's look at his words he said uh
i have today appointed a cabinet to
serve as i will until a new leader is in
place
and he also said that the parliamentary
party the 1922 committee
will announce a timetable next week
now that holds open the possibility that
if they go through the full leadership
election process of mps choosing two
candidates and then those candidates
being voted on by the conservative party
that he could actually have quite a long
caretaker period as he sees it
of course the alternative
and maybe he's put the ball back in the
into the parliamentary party
is that they
the mps here come up with one candidate
uh who would effectively take over
before the end of the month uh now we
saw this before with the transition to
theresa may
and in opposition to michael howard now
if
that happens
then we could have a very very short
transition period for both mr johnson
and this cabinet
but again
he's not making it easy
easier for anyone else uh yeah i mean
he's been in office he highlighted the
things that happened in office
there will be disputes as to how well
the government handled the coveted
crisis for example there will be
disputes uh about whether brexit has
indeed been done
and there will also be
disagreements
as to
whether in other areas of policy mr
johnson has achieved very much at all
but the fact of the matter is
he is now out
uh he will be going uh at the very
latest by this october and the next
party conference
and uh
as enoch powell famously said
all political careers end in failure
uh old they'd certainly do uh don't they
add about adam thank you very much for
guiding us through uh some of the uh
likely consequences now that forest
johnson
has
set out a timetable for resigning
as the leader of the conservative party
and also as prime minister i guess the
question of course many are asking
is whether or not he can continue until
at the autumn we've seen liz trust on
twitter in the last few moments saying
the prime minister's made the right
decision the government under boris's
leadership had many achievements
delivering brexit vaccines in back in
ukraine
we need calmness and unity now she says
and to keep governing that's the
critical bit while a new leader is found
i mean while another mp texts me to say
he's just tried to gaslight the party up
to narcissism to the end so i think that
certainly gives you a bit of a
sense of the range of reactions of mps
to that speech by boris johnson and
potential difficulties i guess in
uniting the party even in the months
ahead well let's bring in our deputy
political editor uh now at shall we sam
coates he's in parliament says central
lobby sam we've been talking to mps
what's the reaction
uh that's right sophie so yes a very
striking very important moment
constitutional moment boris johnson
signals that he will stand down but only
when there is a new conservative party
leader to take over from him an interim
cabinet as it were uh will steward the
country up until that point what do mps
make of it will that position hold well
let's get the first reaction from the
tory mp i'm joined by jonathan gullis
who uh called for boris johnson a couple
of days ago having previously been a
staunch supporter what do you make of
the speech
i thought it was
moving it was difficult to watch to be
honest with you sam look as you say up
until recently i've been very loyal to
the prime minister because i believe he
is instinctively a good man and i'm
grateful for all he did for stoke on
trent with the 56 million for the
leveling up fund 17.6 million kids
growth town deal 31 million bus back
better and 500 new home office jobs this
is a man who understood where
stoke-on-trent north korea's government
talked was it's where he's invested it's
where he's made sure that he delivered
on that brexit uh you know delay that
had been happening so it was it was
difficult to see but i sadly came to the
conclusion as you say a number of days
ago that this simply was untenable and
uh it's painful to watch but it's the
right thing that he's got he called it
eccentric for the party to kick him out
there wasn't much thanks from him to the
conservative party for what they've done
was there any twing of twinge of guilt
any twinge of uh regret when you watched
that speech
when i made that decision to resign as a
parliamentary private secretary which i
appreciate is at the very bottom of the
uh the ladder in terms of ministerial
roles uh i i knew that once i made that
decision that it was the right decision
i haven't regretted it once i'm just sad
that it came to this because i think he
is a good person instinctively and i
think that he could have been and should
have been a great prime minister but
sadly just some poor choices uh over too
long a time it just meant that his
position was untenable there is a very
big live argument going on at the moment
about whether or not boris johnson
should be allowed to continue under the
timetable that he wants which is
possibly some weeks if not months until
the next conservative party leader and
hence prime minister is chosen now that
could be september or october do you
think boris johnson should stay in
downing street until then my personal
preference would have been because of
especially the last 24 hours and the
scenes that we've seen since then that
boris would have gone entirely and we
would have installed dominic raab
as an interim prime minister and then
with the interim cabinet until we had a
new leader however
i trusted graham brady to act on the
behalf of that benches i trust the
interim cabinet they're very good people
so robert buckland who i don't believe
would have gone in there had they not
known that they feel that they would be
making sure that there were firm checks
and balances on boris whilst he
continues obviously as you say until we
elect a new leader so if that's what the
senior members of the party have felt
that they can live with and the
government will most importantly
function and continue to deliver
especially for the people that i'm proud
to represent then i can live with that
do you think that's the settle with the
conservative party as far as it's
possible to judge because we've only had
this speech in a few minutes do you
think collies will accept that timetable
or as you say given the events of the
last 36 48 hours do you think that there
will continue to be a debate on that
matter there probably will be a small
debate on that matter but i think we
have to just bring a closure we don't
need to keep having rows internally we
now need to focus on making sure that we
get a timetable in place to elect a new
leader that new leader get installed as
soon as possible with their cabinet and
that we then get most importantly back
on top of delivering for the people and
focusing on the big issues of the day
it's quite a wide-ranging cabinet from
different wings of the party clearly to
steward through this difficult time but
do you think there should be limits on
what the government over the next few
weeks and months while boris johnson is
still there effectively as a caretaker
should be able to do can boris johnson
make some of the decisions he would have
made anyway or should he just try and
run as steady a low profile as
unambitious uh a ship as possible
because those will be matters for the
next prime minister the prime minister
uh as we still is boris johnson was
elected on a conservative manifesto we
should be delivering that manifesto so
anything within that absolutely we
should be focusing on and also
internationally we can't suddenly stop
helping our friends in ukraine the
northern protocol is something that
clearly needs solving and that boris and
the cabinet agree to so with issues like
that we should be absolutely getting
help for leather on but there are there
is a debate in number 10 about whether
or not to push the button on a packet of
tax cuts changing economic direction are
those the kind of decisions you want to
see with boris johnson still in charge
i trust that the cabinet as it now is
will come around the table look at the
situation we have a global crisis when
it comes to inflation we're seeing
energy bills rising constituents in my
area are clearly worried particularly
about october if it looks like we need
to take action sooner rather than later
then i guess i'll be supportive if any
action needs to be taken to protect
households with their incomes but also
with the rising cost of food and energy
what if there are big issues like the
northern ireland protocol that could be
up for debate in the leadership contest
do you think that the party should just
press on with that bill despite the
international ire difficult
conversations europe not really
responding because they see a change of
leadership in britain on the way how can
you deal with those kind of situations
with a caretaker prime minister maybe
for two months well the northern
protocol if i remember correctly sam you
may correct me didn't have any
conservative member and voted against it
there was a large amount of support for
it and therefore i feel that the prime
minister and the cabinet have a mandate
from the conservative party about
benches to crack on with those issues
thank you very much indeed clearly
difficult day for tory mps but they're
no regrets whatsoever from one person
who has called for boris johnson who's
called for boris johnson to send out
really interesting stuff there uh sam
and certainly from some of the people
that sam has been speaking to and and
he's more generally as well it does feel
as though not everyone is convinced that
boss johnson has bought himself enough
time uh to continue until uh the autumn
a couple of tweets i just want to bring
you uh now from two people who we are
potentially expecting to throw their hat
into the ring for a leadership contest
firstly tom tugan had saying
it's the right call by boris johnson to
resign he delivered brexit rolled up the
vaccine and led on ukraine now we need a
clean start well let's contrast that to
liz trust shall we the foreign secretary
the prime minister has made the right
decision she says the government under
boris's leadership had many achievements
delivering brexit vaccines and backing
ukraine she then says we need calmness
and unity now and to keep governing
while a new leader is
found well let's bring in our political
editor uh beth rigby uh shall we and
beth it does feel doesn't it like the
starting gun has already been found
expired the jostling has started yeah i
mean look the starting gun uh was fired
so uh weeks ago actually this has been
going on for weeks uh mps trying to
corral uh support taking sound ins from
back benches to see who might
be in their camp but now these
leadership vids that we've all been
talking about
behind the scenes are going to come out
into the